joining me here on the rich island show
i've never spoken to this man but i've
um
my entire uh uh i guess teen and adult
life have been
waiting to thank him for all the fun
moments that uh he gave me from the
naked gun trilogy to police squad which
i remember all six episodes
before abc for some reason decided to
cancel it
and of course airplane the 40th
anniversary of the classic film
airplane is being celebrated by a
re-release by fathom events at select
theaters throughout
through september 9th and we'll be
airing at select drive-ins across the
country through november david zucker
the writer and director joining me here
on the show how are you david
i'm good and uh thank you for thanking
me
oh my gosh i mean i i think i need to be
thanked because it was a lot of work and
i'm glad someone appreciates it surely
you're joking david
oh i've heard that one before thank you
though
i'm sorry i just had to go uh in that
direction first you know
it was like you probably missed the
record uh of how long
it took for anybody to mention that but
i love it
well david let me start by asking you
leslie nielsen why him how do you wind
up on your radar screen and thank god
for him
david well you know leslie was the
actually the
the fourth choice uh he was
we we had gone to uh three other actors
who were
more well known vincent price i think
ephron zimbalist jr i mean nobody
remembers these guys now anyway leslie
was the guy who was in the poseidon
adventure and we went to our
casting director at the time for
paramount after having
cast stack bridges and graves in a
comedy
and he was already you know feeling a
little weird about that
that he was going to be responsible for
his name was going to go on this huge
bomb
and we said now we want leslie nielsen
and he he just exploded he said
leslie nielsen leslie nielsen is the guy
you cast the night before
and we were already you know we were a
month away from uh from principal
photography
so we ended up he got it completely he
told his agent
uh don't tell these guys but i pay them
to do this movie so
uh he was perfect he you know he's a
closet comedian although
he had never been in a you know quite
this kind of zany
comedy before but uh he was a fish in
water
well i met him once david he had a
whoopee cushion on him david
right and yeah people ask me you know
did people
have a hard time you know keeping a
straight face because you know all the
jokes are funny and everything but you
know the the jokes aren't
you know after you rehearse them a
million times it's not that funny but
people were cracking up over leslie's
whoopee cushion which he would do it
right in the middle of somebody's line
uh and that's what he did and he did it
on talk shows he was uh
legendary for that and uh i i was
telling the story before david in the
segment before police squad it was six
episodes in 1982
um where he couldn't cancel it fast
enough and that was fine
there were only three networks so you
know
it's you know tony thermopolis at the
time was the uh he was the president of
abc and
uh they were giving him a hard time uh
at a press conference after he canceled
it because i mean
a lot of people did like it and he said
police squad didn't work because you had
to watch it
so it was probably maybe not right for
tv at the time
i think if it were put on today it
probably would do a little better well i
mean and of course
lieutenant frank drebin was born and
then three other films
um coming out of it but i do want to
linger on on on airplane a little bit
because obviously leslie nielsen
is the throughlawn you mentioned robert
stack and peter graves from
mission impossible and then you got
lloyd bridges
as well did you have to twist his arm to
sniff glue and hang upside down
no he he was game you know yeah and and
and stack was hard to get for the part
too he
he was skeptical but once he signed on
he wanted to
uh he wanted more jokes and i think
lloyd
got used to it also i mean at the
beginning i mean in the in the table
read and some of the rehearsals
he wanted to change his lines he wanted
he he was trying to make
sense out of his lines and fine we were
getting a little exasperated
but stack came in and said lloyd just
keep talking they're not listening to us
anyways there's
ears going into the wall watermelons uh
you know crashing into a desk behind us
just keep talking so he did get it and i
think by hot shots
uh he really he really was good well i
mean
did any of these guys i guess they
understand that some of their work
uh was the joke some of their previous
work
they did understand it and it's really
to their credit that
uh they they agreed to make fun of
themselves i mean they all got that
that's what they were doing
david zucker here on the rich eisen show
writer and director of airplane 40 years
i cannot believe it has been that long
right here
on the rich eisen show uh and then who
came up with the idea
to cast kareem abdul-jabbar as peter
graves co-pilot
david well you know that was just a
lucky accident because
we had originally conceived the idea
with pete rose but
it was summer and he was either coaching
or
playing with the reds and
so he wasn't available uh and and so we
went to kareem and
we were able to do much more with kareem
because you know we did the whole
you know to the extent that he was
controversial and we had the kid
call him on it and there there again
he was sending up his own persona and i
think he
up to that time kareem had this image of
being
you know maybe surly and aloof and
but we we found to be to be just quiet i
mean he's perfectly
nice fellow and and and and very you
know very happy to be doing the movie
but uh it completely changed his image
and suddenly
they saw him i mean you know when you
laugh at yourself
you just it just such a a
a token of good will really and uh and
so for the rest of his life he's really
been known
you know a lot for airplane certainly
when he
he told us whenever he travels on a
plane they always
uh want to bring him up to the cockpit
and take a picture with him
and then uh again the the walton and
lanier line
did tell his dad you know have them drag
their ass up and down the court
did he had lived that or did was that it
was everything was written there was no
ad libbing allowed
you know in this but you know jerry and
i
were that's my brother uh you know we we
didn't know
that level of detail about basketball
but jim abrams
uh the other part of the uh the the
triumvirate here
uh knew knew it intimately and so
uh that that's one line i know that jim
jim road
uh because you know he he was you know
very into the whole
you know controversy uh the lakers
the bucks you know because we were from
milwaukee
and uh we followed kareem on
on the box in 1971. so that's how lanier
wound up in there
it's a milwaukee connection walton and
lanier i guess
evidently kareem played against those
guys for nine years
yes indeed i still don't know but yeah
no
i i i totally hear you so pete rose was
originally supposed to be
yeah with peter graves and i dug up some
old scripts please
oh my god can you please tell me what
like it's not even a
fraction as funny as it was with kareem
do you got any good lines that you
wanted pete to say do you got anything
no i mean it was just like
i know you you're pete rose you're the
uh you know
whatever he played for the big
and that was it pretty much and then we
you know when we got the
movie to paramount uh you know we
we couldn't get uh pete rose so we cast
kareem and then we thought i you know so
far back i can't remember
who thought of the idea but we thought
of you know
really developing the whole controversy
or you know people accused them of not
trying and
and etc etc david zucker here on the
rich eisen show
writer and director of airplane 40th
anniversary so
okay there was no ad-libbing huh no no
the script was very well this was this
was the
type of comedy that all all came from
behind the camera i mean it was uh
almost it's like the uberization of of
comedy
we we took the skill uh positions out of
it
and uh and so instead of
you know needing kevin hart or jim
carrey
or you know bill murray chevy chase in
their day
uh we just hired straight actors uh
you know oj was not a comedian either
that's right because
he came later but uh uh you know we we
we just hired all these straight people
and those lines
would not have been as funny if they had
been said by a comedian and then of
course so even something as simple
you know these these dumb puns that we
did like uh
surely you can't be serious right i am
serious and don't call me shirley
you know would not have been funny said
by harvey corman i mean it would have
been
maybe half as funny well i mean and then
of course you know another line that has
lived for on forever is i just want to
let you know good luck we're all
counting on you
i mean just saying and saying it when
everything's over right
and then i even did that in uh scary
movie
three right leslie
leslie played the president in that and
he comes in and says that line it's a
little
nice little call back and then i i mean
again it's
just and then the sense of humor we're
just saying things that are
uh out of uh touch because the moment's
over
and you're not aware the you know uh the
uh robert stack soliloquy talking uh to
stryker
when the plane has already been landed
talking about municipal bonds and
right yeah i mean we were doing as if
elliott ness had talked down the planet
right because we couldn't get anybody to
finance it you know
if you can imagine we were going to
studio saying we want to do a comedy
without comedians
and there's going to be uh and we have
to direct it and there's
three of us you know so they said thank
you very much you know
and then move on and look i never moved
i know we're talking about david zucker
here on the rich eisen show
i know we're talking about airplane but
i do have to ask you about the naked gun
when i um uh broadcast uh for nfl
network i did a game in london with
three other guys in the booth steve
mariucci and kurt warner and michael
urban it was a four-man booth
and the number of times that i got on
twitter and other social media the shot
of the booth from the naked gun
of uh mel allen and dick vitale and dick
enberg and dr joyce brothers
you know like that whole booth that you
had put together how
how did you come up with that idea and
how difficult was it for you to get
every single person
calling them they started having more
and more of these
announcers and you know when they you
did this there was so many so
we did you know nine of them plus dr
joyce brothers
there's always you know you can always
go one step further right
you know we always wanted to try stuff
and that was that gag and it worked
it just worked and i got to meet mel
allen
and all these guys and i think that dick
enberg was honest
right uh and uh tim mccarver
that's right he and that or he was in
basketball well yes they all bleed
together but i just see
all those announcers and then of course
calling the big moment
uh where reggie jackson must kill the
queen um
that is truly one of the most
fascinating moments in the history of
cinema i will say involving mr october
um you know that was great and then yeah
and reggie was reggie was great and uh
and i
later used him in basketball so
well it was just uh you know it was it
was a really great script
written by you know jerry and jim and i
uh and uh and pat proft
well and again um you have to excuse me
i am fanboying out here here because
enrico palazzo uh played by uh
lieutenant frank drebin
played by uh leslie nielsen uh
undercover to try and
uh foil the plot of uh the killing of
the queen
on behalf of ricardo montalban i might
add um the
the the scene the montage of
baseball and sending up baseball
was spectacular and seeing any
umpire basically do
anything other than call a ball and
strike normally i think
of the break dancing and the moonwalking
enrico palazzo
that was fantastic david where did that
one come from
it was just a it was a marvelous idea
to do uh to do a baseball game and it
was just
i mean once we hit on that and in every
movie we figured out
what was the love story between the boy
and the girl in any movie that we did
and then what is the third act that
final third act
and this was just the baseball game
gave us such a great opportunity to do
gags it's just
i mean we could have done more we were
limited by time but uh
yeah i'm just so happy that it worked
out so well and then of course you know
uh
you know i love la being part of that
whole montage and that's what the
dodgers play
after every win these days in the
stadium where everything
obviously was foiled by enrico palazzo
before they ever did that and
uh the dodgers you know be they were
much stricter in those days as you know
okay so they wouldn't let us uh say that
it was the dodgers that's why we had to
use the uh
angels the angels and the mariners i
mean they just didn't want any part of
you know because it may tarnish their
image and those
they didn't allow beards i mean nothing
you know so
well maybe they saw george they saw
george kennedy stick all that food down
his gullet during that montage david and
they didn't want it associated with
their stadium that it clearly was to all
of those yeah
and uh i you know now that i think of it
you know we wanted to use
vin scully because he was our favorite
okay every of anybody
and uh the dodgers wouldn't let us do
that
so vin would have been next to dr joyce
brothers
[Music]
but you know you know what i've always
wanted to do what's that
now that you mentioned i mean i've
always wanted to do a bit and
and i want to i want to do a bit with
vin scully and
it would be um uh kirk gibson's at-bat
yes
and it's and just do that just do that
am
at bat and then have vin scully announce
it
uh and just just announce it and then
but in between a story that he's telling
about vin
and i and his wife uh having
dinner with uh with uh kirk gibson and
his wife
and just some story yeah and then and
then and there's
and it's over the wall it's a home run
we'll be seeing you next tomorrow night
you just said just do a you know not
just ignoring the
the drama of the whole thing unless and
uh i've always wanted to do that
oh man last one for you david i
literally could do this all day
how did you get al michaels and and bob
costas to read that script in basketball
you know it well it turns out everybody
wants to be in a movie
and i think uh costas
was a fan of the the naked guns
and uh and and so and uh we we gave him
the script i was i don't think he read
the script that's the thing
that's what happened he thought it was a
pg-13
naked gun but it turned out you know
basketball was
a little bit uh more rude than that
uh and then and when he saw it i think
he was
uh he was appalled
and cast as we had we had a joke
i see i don't think i'd ever do that
again show anybody
something you know after a few previews
but uh there was a
uh there was one thing where costas was
saying
and everyone is on their feet and then
we panning the stands
and then we get to the wheelchair
section and he says well almost everyone
oh and and he said he he asked me to to
take that
gag out because you know his mother was
uh an invalid in a wheelchair
so i i did but uh
yeah you know but it didn't get a laugh
anyways in the previews
but i wish i had kept it in anyways well
at least the part about uh a certain
part of his chest made it
uh so that that that stuff i know which
he was i he was uh
he was absolutely uh mortified
mortified and appalled that could go up
on the marquee
yeah and and we put it you know this is
how we do it
in the movie business we put the best
gags in the trailer
people come to the theater and so and he
said
did you have to put it in the trailer
yeah
yeah and uh
and then i i think he he
i said we won't put anything in the
movie that doesn't get a laugh i mean i
say that to any actor we won't let you
bomb
and we test the movies and we just don't
want to hang out
anybody out there to drive he evidently
interpreted that
uh to mean i i'll cut out anything you
don't like
and that's i absolutely would not do
that uh
except for you know the wheelchair
section there you go at least you did
that hey david thanks for the call
i could talk all day but i parked in a
white zone so uh
you know thank you yes
uh they're releasing it all over the
country uh with
i think you can go to fathomevents.com
and they're
showing it on netflix and it's a big
re-release
and you got a basketball league you're
forming a league of baseball balls
show that i'm pitching i'm out i'm
pitching it and
that's in the works uh and i want to do
a real
basketball league with you know 10 teams
in major cities
and do everything you know every cliche
of major league sports i want to do in
this uh
in this show david that sounds like a
blast i'd be all in on that for sure
um thanks for the call and thanks for
the laughs thanks for the laughs
really any time you got it thank you
that's david zucker
and for those who are wondering the
white zone is for unloading and loading
of passengers
[Laughter]
vince scully and dr joyce brothers are
here oh my god
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here